global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight from london
at dusk tonight a final flourish capping
off an historic day with a touch of the
commonwealth of nations globe queen
elizabeth's symbolic clay lights a chain
of beacons from windsor castle to
buckingham palace and beyond to
thousands more across britain and the
commonwealth
[Music]
this day was all about the queen bathed
in sunshine and union jacks trooping the
color her official birthday parade was a
spectacle of military precision
her son and heir to the throne prince
charles led it on horseback with prince
william and princess anne by his side
and there to be part of history a sea of
hundreds of thousands of people
no 96 year old has ever had a birthday
like this
for the first time in her 70-year reign
the queen holding a cane stayed in the
palace reviewing the troops from the
balcony
the duchess of cornwall the future queen
consort had shared a carriage with the
duchess of cambridge kate middleton and
her three children prince george prince
louis and princess charlotte no doubt
having practiced their waves beforehand
and then a second balcony moment for the
fly past
four-year-old prince louis was the star
of that one holding his hands over his
ears as more than 70 planes roared
overhead
the queen had decreed only working
royals would appear with her so though
meghan markle and prince harry came to
watch the parade they kept out of public
view
so did prince andrew
good evening and thanks for joining us
we are in london tonight overlooking the
tower of london an ever-present reminder
of the royals long and sometimes bloody
history three english queens were
beheaded at the tower that was hundreds
of years ago of course and though the
modern monarchy is not everyone's cup of
tea the streets of central london today
were flooded with people who love queen
elizabeth late today the palace put out
a statement saying the queen greatly
enjoyed today's birthday parade and fly
past but did experience some discomfort
taking into account the journey and
activity required to participate in
tomorrow's national service of
thanksgiving at st paul's cathedral her
majesty with great reluctance has
concluded that she will not attend it's
another reminder she is in the twilight
of her reign and it's why
so many people turned out wanting to be
here today crystal gamansing has our top
story tonight
in a sea of celebration a unified
message of pride and appreciation for
the queen she's just such a good
worldwide symbol everybody respects her
so yeah she's she's an amazing amazing
lady we're from japan
and we've been living here and then the
royal farm is part of us now
a platinum jubilee is unprecedented for
70 years she has been a steady guiding
hand at home across the commonwealth and
wherever duty has called
remember she was the first royal woman
to join the territorial auxiliary
service as a full-time active member
during the second world war i don't
think we'll ever see him on reaching
this milestone again we just love the
queen
we just wanted to come and see this
while she's still around health issues
have slowed her majesty somewhat
recently particularly her mobility
after contracting kovitch she commented
on how exhausted it made her
thousands doing their part on this day
to lift her spirits as she has theirs i
think the tremendous enthusiasm that
we've seen from the crowds today when
they saw the 96 year old queen on the
balcony a sight we've been wanting to
see for so long i mean this was pleasure
unalloyed while many older citizens here
feel deeply connected to the queen the
only sovereign they've known her
majesty's charisma does cross
generations the queen came to birmingham
for the
diamond jubilee yeah so mum took me to
see the queen
and then the queen asked
my mum how old i was i was wearing this
headband here
and i'm wearing it now in addition to
these big gatherings around the palace
or as close as people can get to the
palace there are also more than 16 000
street parties planned for the platinum
jubilee and about 70 000 lunches across
the uk
we're having so much fun it's so good to
see her the festivities led to a chance
meeting for these two an american and a
canadian who last saw each other camping
out for harry and megan's wedding in
windsor
it is totally remarkable and and what's
interesting is when we've talked about
this is you really have to be here you
have to be here you have to be amongst
everyone to feel it another jubilee
treat the nighttime lighting of beacons
once a means of communication now one of
celebration more than 3 thousand lit up
across britain and elsewhere including
canada house here in london as well as
one back in ottawa
donna
all right crystal command singh thank
you here's one way to put this moment
this platinum jubilee on a timeline the
queen has reigned longer than i and most
people in the crowd today have been
alive no one under the age of 70 has
known another queen
no one actively involved in the parade
today will take part in another platinum
jubilee this is the first one there's
ever been and it's highly unlikely there
will ever be another that's why
everything was on such a grand scale
more than 70 aircraft roared over in the
flypast including this surprise
aerobatic feat
raf typhoons formed into the number 70
winging their way over the palace as the
queen beamed this day was about both her
public role and her role as a mother
grandmother and great-grandmother
she has not yet met harry and megan's
daughter lillabet who turns one on
saturday and there's speculation about a
family gathering and a birthday party at
windsor castle
one final note on the royals tonight
prince andrew has coveted and won't be
able to attend the surface of
thanksgiving tomorrow at st paul's
cathedral it had been unclear what role
he would play in his mother's platinum
jubilee he's been stripped of his royal
titles and duties over his friendship
with convicted sex offender jeffrey
epstein and after paying to settle a
civil lawsuit against him over sexual
abuse allegations
now two news in canada prime minister
justin trudeau was in alberta today he
signed an historic 1.3 billion dollar
land claim settlement with the sixtique
first nation east of calgary the
agreement resolves outstanding land
claims dating back more than a century
when canada broke its treaty promise and
took almost half of six second nations
land
the government
acted dishonorably
including by taking more than fifteen
thousand
acres sorry 115 000
acres of your most productive
agricultural and mineral-rich lands
for the benefits of others
the
nation voted in december to accept the
payment for the wrongful surrender of
the land the federal government says it
is one of the largest settlements of its
kind in canada
[Applause]
ontarians are voting today the
month-long election campaign there
focused on affordability health care and
infrastructure is over the leaders of
ontario's four main parties cast their
ballots this morning unless opinion
polls are way off base doug ford is
expected to win again as eric sorenson
explains rewarding a first-time
government with a second mandate is
almost standard practice in ontario
that's ontario's premier doug ford
climbing into a backhoe promising a new
highway it's time to start pouring the
concrete it's time to get paving a new
road through ontario's green belt faced
stiff opposition from environmentalists
and the other three major party leaders
doug ford seems to be obsessed with
destroying farmland destroying wetlands
but controversies whether about roads
the pandemic or the economy have done
little to drag down doug ford we're just
performing better than i think anybody
expected they would be at this point who
has the best shot
at unseating doug ford opposition leader
andrea horvath may have the best shot
but ontario's history is not encouraging
for her
the ndp has won just once and premier
bob ray was voted out the very next
election
most often ontario voters alternate
between liberals and conservatives and
almost always give them more than one
kick at the can
starting in 1923 with howard ferguson to
mitchell hepburn to george drew drew
kicking off 42 years of conservative
rule then came david peterson mike
harris and dalton mcginty mcginty
starting 15 years with the liberals in
power and now doug ford like the others
with one term behind him and looking for
reelection
ontario voters aren't by nature
impulsive and electing ford already
represented a big change just four years
ago it's not like the ontario voter is
fickle
when they make a change it's an emphatic
change
and they're prepared to stick with the
journey maybe a little longer than just
one term that makes it hard for the
opposition who are just as preoccupied
with defeating each other ndp have lost
their way a bitter struggle that could
decide who'll be the official opposition
the liberals already broke all these
things how can you trust them to fix
them add to that mike schreiner and the
green party taking a percentage of the
progressive vote and doug ford's
conservatives have sailed along with a
simple message it's time to finish the
job
it's time to get it done in ontario
first-time governments not only tend to
win re-election they normally get a
majority second time around
reason for optimism if you're doug ford
eric sorensen global news toronto
and you can track the ontario election
results across several platforms on
global news tonight starting at 7 30
eastern
tulsa oklahoma is the latest u.s city
left grieving and angry after a mass
shooting four people were killed by a
gunman who walked into a medical
facility last night
among the victims a doctor who'd
recently performed back surgery on the
suspect police believe the weapons were
purchased legally including a
semi-automatic rifle bot just hours
before the shooting
there have now been 20 mass shootings in
the u.s since 19 children and two
teachers were killed at that school in
uvalde texas and that was just over a
week ago
the united kingdom became the latest
western nation to pledge a fresh batch
of weapon deliveries to the ukrainian
military in a bid to help counter
russia's onslaught on the country's
eastern donbass region
uk officials say they will send an
unspecified number of medium-range
rocket systems which can fire precision
guided rockets up to 80 kilometers away
the decision was reportedly coordinated
closely with the u.s which made its own
weapons announcement yesterday russia
has warned of repercussions as it
continues to devastate cities in eastern
ukraine ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky says russian forces now control
about 20 percent of the country the
battle line stretching more than one
thousand kilometers
the world reacts to a global news
exclusive coming up the response to
claims chinese fighter pilots are
harassing their canadian counterparts
reaction is pouring in from around the
world after a global news exclusive
about chinese fighter pilots flying
dangerously close to canadians in
international airspace as canada
participates in the un mission abigail
beeman is following the story we broke
and brings us the latest
this is a disturbing report reads a
tweet from the other side of the world
about the global news exclusive that
chinese fighter pilots are getting
dangerously close to canadians in
international airspace the un mission to
enforce sanctions on north korea is
called operation neon the u.n commander
who tweeted overseas bases including the
one in japan that houses the canadian
plane in question
no official response yet from beijing
but the story is reverberating around
the globe picked up by outlets including
the bbc reuters and cnn to worry about
the chinese jets buzzing canadian
aircraft has the u.s also seen an
increase in these types of chinese
provocative actions reporters inquiring
at a u.s state department briefing i
would need to refer you to the
department of defense to speak to any
particular trend lines we
have spoken of prc's provocative
military activity
in the region here at home the prime
minister called the situation extremely
troubling we will be
bringing up it up directly with chinese
officials and counterparts
and ensuring that this doesn't
continue to be part of an escalatory
pattern exactly how canada plans to do
that is not clear
china's military is unprofessional and
poorly trained and does not follow the
rules
while the opposition wants canada to
spend more on defense meeting nato's 2
percent of gdp target i think it's a
hallmark of other militaries
that we've seen such as russia's
military in ukraine which has equally
been reckless
and
unprofessional
with eyes around the globe watching
abigail b minute global news ottawa
ahead how relevant is the royal family
in 2022
we are overlooking the tower of london
tonight a fortress a royal palace and an
infamous prison
we're back in a moment
welcome back to london we are right next
to tower bridge tonight
well one man told me today he didn't
used to like the queen much but now he
believes she cares more about the people
than many politicians here
she is in the twilight of her reign and
what comes next will define how relevant
the monarchy remains plenty of canadians
have fond feelings for her but others
view the monarchy with indifference or
even indignation
ross lord is exploring that tonight
a beloved icon the queen still draws big
crowds especially in london on her
platinum jubilee but with changing views
about the damaging impacts of british
colonialism there are growing questions
about how long the royals will remain
relevant the royal family has been
through a bit of a reckoning in the past
few years at prince andrew what's
happened with prince harry and meghan
markle as well
as well as the royal tours not going so
well earlier on this year and some
island nations in the caribbean talking
about removing the queen as head of
state barbados has already split from
the monarchy shedding ties with its
historical british oppressors among
those leading the charge was this
canadian woman who was born in barbados
and now teaches at mcgill university
it's a psychological message of
you no longer
control us even though they haven't been
for years
but
you don't longer control us we're
looking you now in the eye
as equals at prince charles and
camilla's royal tour of canada last
month modest sized crowds still mustered
enthusiasm we've grown up with the
royals and tradition all our lives you
know the queen is our head of state stop
it
just stop it we have fun here go away
they've done nothing wrong with the
politicians but public opinion polls
indicate more than half of canadians
want to break with the monarchy a
sentiment that's grown in recent years
and may continue to as canadians reckon
with the crown's connection to
indigenous residential schools other
countries like jamaica could soon break
away and more may follow and i think it
will be countries that we don't expect
like canada like australia
that will say you know what the royal
family doesn't really work for this new
multicultural cultural multicultural
country that we are building if canada
ever does split from the monarchy it
would take a lot of effort including
amending the constitution some say it's
more likely the royal family simply
becomes less important and less
interesting to citizens their influence
gradually fading away ross lord global
news
next of all the queen's horses she was
the one the canadian mayor the queen
road for years
that is the chard a skyscraper in london
sparkling at the top like a crown we're
back in a moment
[Music]
welcome back to london
one of the queen's greatest loves is
horses she has a keen interest in
breeding and bloodlines she owns
racehorses and up until recently she
still rode herself the rcmp have given
her eight horses over the years and for
a long time one of those horses played a
starring role
in the trooping of the color
for decades this is how the queen led
her birthday parade on horseback riding
side saddle dressed in a scarlet
military uniform
for 18 of those years she rode the same
striking black mare named burmese so her
favorite horse ever was burmese
he was a a gift from the royal canadian
mounted police
he was probably well her most reliable
horse born in saskatchewan burmese was
bred to be a police horse but when the
queen who is a keen and skilled rider
was looking for a new horse burmese was
offered as a gift
sergeant major scott williamson is the
rtmp riding master and has met the queen
several times her majesty herself is an
amazing horse woman very accomplished
horse woman knows horses in and out and
takes a very special interest in her
horse riding skills and equitation
skills in 1981 those skills were put to
the test prince philippe
colonel of the grenadier guards during
her birthday parade
six shots ran out startling burmese and
the queen you hear a bang and you think
what the blazes is going on it could
only be something could be a firearm the
queen quickly got control of the horse
gave her a reassuring pat and carried on
calmly the man who fired the shots which
turned out to be blanks
was apprehended she doesn't panic
whatever the
how grim the situation is she just
doesn't panic and the queen's main
concern was was burmese and burmese was
fine the bond was unbreakable from 1969
to 1986 the queen rode burmese in every
trooping the color and she wrote her for
pleasure too here she is with former u.s
president ronald reagan she on burmese
he on another canadian horse centennial
her love of burmese was unmatched when
burmese retired from parades and public
duties the queen said right i'm retiring
too from those i'm not going to ride
anymore because without burmese it won't
be the same
from then on the queen road in a
carriage burmese lived out her years on
the grounds of windsor castle where the
queen could visit her and when the horse
died she was buried on the grounds of
the castle a rare honor in 2005 queen
elizabeth went back to saskatchewan to
dedicate this statue outside the
legislature her beloved black mare lives
on in the place where she was born
and that is global national from london
for this thursday night i'm donna frieza
and we leave you with more moments from
the platinum jubilee parade for the
queen the palace says she enjoyed it
greatly but as exciting as it was it
must have been taxing for her she will
not attend the church service tomorrow
is planned though the palace insists
she's in good spirits and very much in
charge behind the scenes there are three
more days of celebrations to come and we
will bring it all to you
for now thanks for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow from london
so
[Music]
you